[Music]
this is an action movie seeing all of
that in imax is the way you want to see
this I mean it was amazing before you
were there with the characters such a
great places near build a bridge for a
boxing start second time in imax felt
like i was in the movie empire there's a
huge story if you don't see it in imax I
mean you're really doing yourself a
disservice because just to see the
clarity of picture and to see it with
that kind of added cinematic value is
just amazing the best fun that I loved
seeing the smile on the faces release
tonight
if the guys movie feel is for everybody
to enjoy transported to the world yeah i
think is the hallway very holy yet the
combination of town sighs EG i was
flawless but technically it was pretty
amazing even more than the picture like
the sound is so amazing and imax that
you get to here like the whole orchestra
and everything plus like visual effects
look really cool huge strain smoldering
a woman besides now I definitely not the
only way to say the picture was amazing
the sound quality was superior
everything's better now in linear in the
60s all extremely for one on imax
exactly please also found everything for
the world oh my gosh this is such an
insane cinematic experience i want to
see you again already seeing it in imax
is the only way to see
[Music]
you
you